we are digging into dancing history here
you guys
so judge carrie ann used to date pro
artem and fans think that's why she is
now coming hard
for artem's partner caitlyn bristow
is this personal or are we being held to
a different standard
i'm a little torn right now no no it was
another not great dance of yours
i was not super impressed it starts
being a little personal i feel it does
you are an amazing dancer but it's a
competitive season
who all you want people what do you
think caitlyn i just want to know
like where it comes from then it's just
a jump
it's not a jump that she can do on her
own this is the jump it's the back
technician and he's
lifted her through the tuck sorry i'm
gonna keep fighting for it after monday
night's war
of words fans pounced on carrie anne's
near
constant criticism one tweeting just
because you and artem used to date
there's no need to be so hard on caitlyn
bristow
i think carrie anne totally would have
saved us and not because you guys dated
but she really liked my technique last
year artem's now fiance nikki teased him
about it the pair was together for two
years after meeting on the set of so you
think you can dance back in 2005.
to be fair carrie ann has since been
judging her ex on dancing for
nine seasons without issue on the talk
carrie anne didn't acknowledge the
internet's theories
but did address her haters it doesn't
make me change the way i judge i'm not
about to change because you're trying to
bully me
it only makes me stand stronger in my
convictions than what i believe it is
and i felt like your spirit dropped
and then but listen i don't want to
discourage you caitlyn threw out her own
theory for carrie anne's criticism oh
but i was hard on hannah and you're
another bachelor girl
oh my god no i don't want it okay sorry
i'm sorry after tearfully hashing it out
with the dancing judge last year
hannah b went on to win so maybe being
in carrie anne's crosshairs
isn't all that bad either way artem has
a strategy for next week
and i'm buying air moths so i can flag
him in
during the judges
you